Speaker 1: This is fascinating.
Last week, when Ron DeSantis responded to
Trump's attack on him by saying, I don't spend
my time attacking other Republicans, DeSantis
took the high road as we discussed.
I told you, this isn't going to work for DeSantis,
and I have expressed concerns previously that
in a national campaign, DeSantis, who lacks
all charisma, I mean, just completely uncharismatic.
I don't know how to.
Santos faces off against Trump and the nicknames
and the attacks in a national campaign.
I'm not the only one saying this.
This is really interesting.
There's a New York Times article published
two days ago called DeSantis Challenge When
and How to Counterattack Trump.
The article is by Michael Bender and Maggie
Haberman.
And in this article, they actually address
this issue.
He's trying to take the high road, but that
is not likely to work.
And there's a paragraph that says some deep
pocketed Republican donors have privately
expressed concern about how DeSantis will
perform when forced to directly engage with
an opponent as combative and unbothered by
traditional rules of decorum as Mr. Trump.
Liam Donovan, a Republican strategist, said
No Republican has ever emerged from an exchange
with Donald Trump looking stronger.
So the natural tendency is to deflect attacks
and avoid confrontation.
That's easy to do, maybe wise, when Trump's
barbs are confined to truth social.
The question is what happens when DeSantis
finds himself on a debate stage opposite Trump
and Republicans vote?
Republican voters want to see whether they
are getting what they were promised.
I think this article is exactly right, and
I think that the Republicans who are bringing
this up are 100% justified in being concerned
with this.
And the article mentions all of these, you
know, different attacks that Trump launched
against challengers in 2016, insinuating that
Ted Cruz, his father, was linked to the assassination
of John F Kennedy, calling Ben Carson pathological,
making fun of the appearance of Ted Cruz,
his wife, and of Rand Paul and so on and so
forth.
This is exactly right.
And so while I believe that, at least in theory
right now, Ron DeSantis is well positioned
for a run against Trump, if he announces and
if he takes the campaign seriously and he'll
he has a shot, there's no doubt.
But if they emerge as the frontrunners, Trump
and DeSantis, and if they end up on stage
against each other and DeSantis does this
high road stuff while Trump brutally attacks
the Santos and he will, it doesn't look good
for DeSantis.
I don't actually believe that Republican voters
are going to be swayed by a guy who takes
the high road.
I think they want to see who here brings the
sort of like, you know, what they what they
wrongly believe to be alpha energy and whatever
else.
And I don't think the Santos taking the high
road will work.
And DeSantis does need to figure out how do
I attack Trump, When do I attack Trump or
the chance that he has it?
This thing is going to very quickly evaporate.
Let me know your thoughts.
What should DeSantis approach be?
And we will certainly have time to discuss
this further.
Trump has started to go after DeSantis in
casual conversations, they say, describing
him as all sorts of different strange things
based on his physical appearance.
So Trump seems to be winding it up.
And even though Trump says he's not thinking
about it, all of the indications are that
he is Trump's going to be ready.
This is you know, Trump's not going to be
ready with that health care plan that we were
going to get in August of 2020.
I'm not holding my breath waiting for that
health care plan.
Trump is going to be ready for how to attack
Ron DeSantis, and DeSantis has to figure out
what to do.